does your friend often do that strange
all right what is your job exactly
besides Megan balloon animals
protecting your reality
[Music]
mahmu I come to hey everybody it's
Charlie awesome news Kevin Feige
recently confirmed that they are going
to be doing a Doctor Strange sequel I
think we all expected them to do it at
some point
but now he's made it official oh yeah
we're definitely working on it during
phase four so we got to break this down
because there's like three or four
really big things that they have to wrap
up from the first Doctor Strange movie
and what happens during the events of
infinity war and Avengers 4 so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video so we think most
of us believe that he is inside the soul
world of the soul gem along with all the
other people that were turned to ash so
they're probably only a few people that
are inside though that are powerful
enough to understand or communicate with
the people on the outside world I don't
consider it a spoiler to say that there
are moments in ant-man and the wasp that
connected to Avengers 4 I briefly
touched on that during my non-spoilery
review but it goes a little bit deeper
than you think so we have to wait a
little while to talk about that till
everybody has a chance to see the movie
but there's some practical ways that
explain how Doctor Strange is still
around despite the fact that it seems
like he's dead in terms of timing just
to give you an idea for how much other
story is gonna be unfolding in the MCU
before we get to a doctor strange sequel
they haven't announced a writer for the
script they have an announced to
director so I'm guessing that any Doctor
Strange sequel that they make won't drop
till well after Guardians
- and that's 2020 in the spring so
either fall 2020 if they get started
really soon or the next year after that
he also said that henceforth they're
doing three movies per year not
including any potential Fox x-men movies
if that deal goes through so there's
gonna be a whole lot of stuff happening
before we get another Doctor Strange
solo film and when I say solo film
that's a bit misleading because we're
probably gonna get some Avengers
crossover in that - they've been a lot
of people asking about a Scarlet Witch
movie because she wants to continue
playing the character in the Marvel
Universe they've given her an arc across
these last couple of films with vision
totally developing her powers but
putting Scarlet Witch in a Doctor
Strange movie would be a great place for
her to learn about her chaos magic from
the comics
also hoping for a little Peter Parker
spider-man crossover because of the
proximity in New York City but by the
time we get to a dr. strange movie we
will have probably already gotten our
third spider-man film meaning that he
would have graduated from high school
and we don't know if he's going to be
going to college in this universe I
think the more important thing to talk
about is the fact that he won't be a kid
anymore he'll be like a full blown
Avenger adult spider-man there are a
couple of big things that are happening
during infinity war and Avengers four
that have serious consequences after
what happened during the Doctor Strange
movie so what happened at the end of
that movie 1 Baron Mordo said there are
entirely too many sorcerers he doesn't
like the way that Doctor Strange is
messing around with the natural order of
things
even though Doctor Strange believes that
what he's doing is necessary for the
greater good so at the end of the movie
more dough goes around killing all
sorcerers starting with pain born it's
implied that ever since that moment he's
continued that quest just going around
the world slowly killing all magic users
off but the other really big thing
Dormammu I've come to bargain remember
what was that bargain based on the fact
that Doctor Strange possessed the time
stone and it's implied now that Thanos
has it that he might be free to invade
this reality it even if Dormammu might
still be afraid of Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet and that might be
holding him at bay the whole idea is is
that by the end of Avengers 4 we might
wind up with either an infinity watch
situation or the gems themselves scatter
or are destroyed so that going into
Phase four phase 5 they're not this big
MacGuffin that exists for people to find
like they effectively just wiped the
Infinity stones off the board as a story
device going forward so if you're not
familiar with the comics the Infinity
watch is basically Adam warlock putting
together a team of six starting with
Thanos
to protect the Infinity stones after
they separate them after the events of
the Infinity Saga like Thanos has a bit
of a change of heart he becomes more of
an antihero so he becomes the guardian
of the reality gem but in that scenario
back during the 90s all the Infinity
stones still existed in more recent
years what Marvel has done when there's
a big infinity style saga involving the
stones is that usually when people try
to wield them either they're cracked or
the gems themselves scatter across all
of
reality and sometimes time like they can
change their physical properties
remember these are supposed to be all
powerful devices so I would assume that
the Infinity stones are gonna be wiped
off the board somehow at the end of
Avengers 4 so that nobody else can use
them meaning that the bargain that
Doctor Strange made with Dormammu in the
Dark Dimension is null and void that
he's free to come back and invade our
dimension but remember dr. Strange's
main task is sorcerer supreme is
protecting the earth from other
realities that's the whole purpose of
the sanctums 2 they create that
protective enchantment around so if one
of the sanctums goes down the barrier
goes down and the earth becomes
susceptible to invasion from all manner
of magical creatures from other
dimensions
people like Mephisto remember we did see
a version of Ghost Rider and agents of
shield meaning that he started with
Mephisto Mephisto is the person that
initially created the Ghost Rider
character so he has to exist out there
somewhere but what I'm hoping is is that
if they wait long enough to do the
sequel they include dr. doom in that
because dr. doom is a character that has
one foot in the realm of magic one foot
in the realm of technology one thing we
haven't seen them address in the
fantastic four movies that we've seen
him in before is the magical side of his
character he's just as smart as dr.
strange is is that his hubris usually
brings him down remember he's supposed
to be a villain in technical terms more
of an antihero in his own eyes they
missed a lot with the characters
alignment after all-new all-different
like for a very brief period he kind of
filled in for Iron Man as the
irredeemable Iron Man so we see him
again in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
there's just a number of different ways
they could portray him but I think that
they would go more with antihero leaning
closer to villain there's a lot of you
that are asking about an Illuminati
movie after Avengers 4 like is this the
creation of the Illuminati I think they
would definitely save that for an
Avengers film because it involves so
many of their biggest characters but
because that does involve x-men based
characters I think those are just wait
till they can use them so maybe Avengers
5 Avengers 6 down the road so I don't
think that we'll see that during a
Doctor Strange sequel the new order of
the day remember is as they do those
crossovers like Hulk showing up in Thor
Ragnarok but the stories themselves are
still relatively self-contained
with maybe like a brief stinger that
pushes into whatever the next big over
are
is and a lot of that will just depend I
think on what's going on with this Fox
Disney deal but secret invasions secret
Wars there's just a number of different
directions that could go but just plan
on the Doctor Strange sequel being story
that you could really only tell with his
character which means multiple
dimensions magical creatures demonic
creatures people like Dormammu in
Mephisto things that you would not
expect to see pop up in a spider-man
film this early in his story like
they're not gonna be doing any one more
day or anything like that anytime soon
what'll happen is is because they're
announcing more of these phase four
movies I'll wait a little bit longer
like after a man and the wasp and we'll
talk about what's happening next because
there'll be a lot of really cool really
weird stuff going down but leave all
your requests in the comments below I
wasn't expecting this so while NEMA a
new giveaway winner when I post new
Marvel that should be new Iron Fist
Heroes for Hire that should be up in a
little while while you wait for that
click here for brand new Captain Marvel
and Avengers 4 and click here for my
non-spoilery ant-man the wasp review
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]